Nelson FBI has a podcast Mandela ok how
many done so far
[Music]
Gary Vaynerchuk is with us today he's a
social media guru of marketing master
he's actually one of the first ever
YouTube star and so you've turned a wine
company that your your family started
into this is I was thinking like a
couple million dollars here into tens of
millions of dollars a year your
best-selling the author you run this
little thing called vaynermedia which is
something like 100 million plus and
revenue so a million different things
going on we're really happy to have you
thanks for coming in Gary thanks for
being like yeah of course so I want to
talk all the way about going back to the
beginning to the beginning the childhood
okay a lot of people think that you know
from the success that you've had maybe
you came from success but your
beginnings are pretty humble you know
it's funny if I was listening right now
and didn't know the person I actually
think a lot of times that people that
are successful we made it I'm actually
one of the few people or maybe the
majority I don't know it's so funny I
actually think my kids are gonna have a
harder time being successful than I was
I think being born in Belarus coming
here with nothing my parents working
every minute that instilled a huge
competitive advantage a chip on my
shoulder a work ethic that I you know I
think there's a very big reason that in
the American meritocracy system to the
you know by comparison and there's
always stuff but in capitalism or the
version that we've lived in the last 50
years in America immigrants win a lot
and they went a lot because of a couple
core things so yeah I didn't start with
a lot you know I have friends who
started with a lot of now built on top
of it and I'm impressed because I used
to think that was a disadvantage so I
think there's a million ways to do it I
like them now I like my dad's narrative
the best I mean he was 22 when he came
to America had nothing so that's a
really amazing story I'll take mine no
and so baseball cards lemonade yeah I
wasn't all that kids trying to do and
there's actually
so you had a series of lemonade yes yes
yeah I mean I didn't know it was a
franchise when you're six I just knew
that there was a lot of kids in my
neighborhood and I thought Marissa bird
and they were at Godfrey and Robbie turn
ik she put in a good day's of work so
you know yeah I've always had the knack
for and actually what I was about to say
I just always had a knack for branding
so like even with the lemonade stands it
was like Gary's lemonade stands and I
worked on the signs all day more so than
the lemonade itself and then I learned
how to make the lemonade to build an
actual business so that taught me
lifetime value and quality like I
learned a lot as a kid I was a very poor
student which was really unusual for
immigrants but I didn't see education as
my way out I knew that I had it and that
originally started as I'm a good
salesman and then was I'm a good
businessman and then it was I'm a good
operator and now the current term is I'm
a good entrepreneur so yeah it's it's a
DNA thing with me back house my dad you
know first was a stock boy then was a
manager then say don't you know an
amazing piece of advice for a lot of
kids 50 year olds whoever's listening
right now is like saving money is a good
strategy like we didn't have like I
didn't have stuff but it was because my
parents were saving they were saving
they were saving and my mom spent we
didn't get toys like go outside him like
paint a rock right it was like very very
smart because after seven or eight years
he was able to buy a liquor store of his
own in Springfield New Jersey shoppers
discount liquors he built up a great
business 44 million dollar a year
business like made it right like
literally made it middle class upper
middle class made it we didn't ever need
anything they didn't spend a lot they're
big savers but we made it and then I got
dragged into it at 14
you know oldest son on one of three I
was the oldest son
yeah because nobody was really checking
good you know good question that's
probably not 16 you could get a permit
but I was in there 14 that's probably
why they put me in the basement bagging
ice stocking shelves and somewhere
around 16 17 I realized that people
collected wine and that caught my
attention because I was deep into
baseball cards and comic books at that
point and and I really really enjoyed
learning the wine world and really
became fascinated by it and that all
manifests that a couple years later to
me launching in 1996 a site called
winelibrary.com we rebranded the store
to Wine Library and and that started my
first chapter right it grew the business
from three to four million dollar your
business to earn it with initially a 45
and a 60 million dollar a year business
in a very short period of time on the
back of what I love reading your stuff
about which is business innovation you
know email marketing having a website 21
years ago for a single store wine shop
liquor shop in New Jersey was like
having a VR studio in a flower shop
right now in Iowa in it early I mean
there was like you know there was there
was there was wine calm got like a
trillion dollars in funding it was so
early there was literally not 10 I went
on the internet you know in 94 and in 4
seconds landed on an AOL bulletin board
where people sold baseball cards and I
just knew the same way I knew that
Twitter would be big and that's why
invested or tumblr or Facebook or uber
you know I've done snapchat I've done
really well on one core principle which
is I think I have intuitive ability to
understand consumer behavior more than
the average there and I'm not scared to
bet the farm on that gut feel right and
so even online dating
Katie right in 2003 when it was right
and when it was super like sacrilege
no it was free on New York Jewish dating
scene was pretty hoppin but I just
remember thinking like in ten years
every single person I didn't think
they'd be swiping to the right but like
I'm like every person's gonna do this
because this is practical and so people
are romantic people like well I'll never
buy a tomato on the Internet this is
what I heard in 96 I'm like yeah well
cuz time is valuable because other
things matter more and so I knew because
I thought people need buy stuff on the
Internet
long before a lot of people thought I
think the thing that I'm most proud of
is that when people try to take a res at
me as like a self-promoter and I'm very
empathetic to that because I do so much
away on my personal brand I'm empathetic
but if they even spent four seconds
digging and realizing I didn't say a
word until I was money from in 30s and
had already built enormously large
business at least not by tech standards
but no cash infusion ten percent gross
profit liquor store in the mid 90s to
grow to that scale was very hard right
vaynermedia has been fun for me I would
tell you secretly and I haven't said
this so I'm trying to give you a nugget
for your podcast I needed to build what
vaynermedia for myself because I was
starting to become garyvee to your point
the wine video is kind of put me on the
map I read a book in 2009 called crush
it which gets me into the you're a
motivational speaker
you're a pundit you're a-- and it
started becoming about my personality
and me on twitter more than my business
accomplishments so I needed Vayner I
needed to build an agency against the
biggest firms on Madison Avenue and I
needed this big success even to just
remind myself that I'm entrepreneur an
operator an actual businessman first I'm
not what I think there's a lot of right
now which is a lot of people running
around and saying they're an
entrepreneur on Instagram I'm proud of
that you know like I look at something
that is upsetting to me what I
yip-yap sell for 4 million dollars you
know I feel bad for the guys thank you
correct but I don't feel bad because
that's entrepreneurship that's business
and I think a lot of people are getting
confused right now of what success
actually looks like only a very few will
break through and actually sell their
business actually go public actually
make it and and I have a lot of pride in
the fact that since the day I graduated
from college
I've run two businesses every day of my
life either wine library or vaynermedia
no one between know being a personality
no being a speaker it may feel that way
because of the content I put out but
every day of my life for the last 20
years I've been the CEO or operator of a
business every single day and both of
them are massively all-time successful
within nerd I worked my face off and I
learned my craft like how many hours
like you know I slept but like I worked
everything give you an example there's
not a lot of 20 year olds who can say
they work every single Saturday of their
entire 20s period I did I worked 52 52
Saturdays a year from 22 to 29 until I
met my wife and started having for the
build some level of work-life balance
what about to wine library at 7:30 in
the morning and I left it 7 8 or 9 I
just worked I just built a management
staff I just tasted wine I just built up
the website learned how to do Google
AdWords you know I just worked and that
when I thought you work like just I was
a I am and was a workaholic and and I
and and and I didn't say a word right
like I didn't do pod
I didn't you know there wasn't social
media but there was I didn't start a
MySpace page to say look at me look what
I'm doing I had me outlets
I built my craft that became a great
wine taster which allowed me to taste
1520 wines a day during my day I would
taste 15 or 20 wines you'd be a
salesperson from Enrique - wine company
in New York and I would taste 12 wines
from you and I'd say wow that third
Rioja you only want $9 for it but it
tastes like $40 Rioja and then I would
look it up and be like okay it's selling
for $15.99 on the Internet
that's $9 hey if I pick 50 cases will
you do seven get that the death I mean a
business over the merchants right and
I'm just cleaning up my people I'm
strength training Brandon Wernicke to be
able to replace me like quote-unquote
got hit by a bus and I was watching
trends and I and that's what led me to
youtube I'm like this is gonna be big oh
wait a minute I can't buy ads on this
like I can an ad roll or on Google you
know what do I do with this should I
should I get a camera and just talk
about why it sounds like not a bad idea
I mean content is important but I didn't
call it content right I mean like this
world didn't exist that we all live in
now like but I thought about Emeril
Lagasse when I did it like I thought
about that so I just started reviewing
wine that did take off as you mentioned
know the first year you know I started
on February 20th 2006 in July of 2007 a
year and a half later the break happened
it was still quite small but I got
invited to be on the Conan O'Brien show
and you're a youngster so I don't know
where you are at this point but the
internet that the web 2.0 world which
was a seed to the world we're in now
daring fireball is a blog TechCrunch
Jason cocky Emil - wack c.org these are
love it so perfect so that whole crew up
the front page of dig right metafilter
you know that whole like you know just
fun to like write that whole world and I
know if you remember this but basically
that whole world and some of the small
Twitter people Scoble calcaneus Kevin
Rose I just seen Pete Cashmore in
Mashable everybody and I mean everybody
wrote about me being uncommon cuz it was
like like YouTube personal Conan and
then the clip was awesome I got him to
eat dirt and grass it went viral on
YouTube and that pretty much that took
me from being a top 500 followed person
on Twitter to a top 50 person followed
on Twitter then Kevin Rose asked me to
be on Digg nation then you know I was on
The Today Show and Ellen and and then it
started rolling nothing he saw nothing
he had no idea who it was a producer of
that show cousin was watching it thought
I was funny and they have these pitch
meetings right we're like what should we
do there is a weird guy in the Internet
who's like talking about wine in a very
different way they called me I had
always thought what would happen if that
happened so I had the idea of not Conan
but I thought what if daytime TV or
morning TV yeah of course I mean I
already think about like what I'm gonna
be doing with on Alexa voice and what am
I going to be doing on VR and and how am
I gonna use message spots and what's
gonna happen when my kids are 18 and
like when I buy the Jets like who's
gonna be my GM like I um you know I it's
definitely not gonna be Ben Lehrer I'm
not I'm gonna let him in the stadium I
think that I think that you know by the
way I met I reference spend earlier been
his dad was very successful and to watch
how hard Ben has built Thrillist and the
group nine network it's just very
inspiring it makes me hope that my
children will have that fire even though
it's not these are trillion everybody
it's stuff way more than I did
right and so Ben matters to me a lot i
rana CLE that you brought him up because
he he showed me very closely he's a
friend of mine hey you can have stuff
but still be on fire and doing so he
that's been fun for anyway yeah I like
playing the loud obnoxious guy and
downplay how I think about things but
I'm starting to get in tune with my
strategical self I think it's important
because I don't want care
- just think being an extroverts enough
to build a business and so I've started
ironically communicating it was probably
the second time I'm doing this I think a
lot like honey listen I didn't launch
one of the early ecommerce businesses I
didn't have an email service that had
90% open rates I wasn't a buyer on
Google AdWords a day came out I didn't
know I as a liquor store owner didn't by
accident know who and II by oh and Jason
coffee and meal - bug like I've been
right about consumer trends so yeah I
thought about what if somebody calls me
and I had this idea of like I'll train
their palate by eating funny things that
will make good TV it did and that became
the beginning then YouTube sells YouTube
sells I correct
one point seventh right oh my god it was
one point seven and just for everybody
at home if musically sells tomorrow to
Viacom for 250 billion dollars that's
what it felt like it was such a big
number right everything's a billion now
that he's a piece of crap
right back that was remember it was in
st. so I said holy crap I was right
about EECOM I was right about Google
AdWords I was right about email I was
right about retargeting banner ads I'm
right about blogging now I'm right about
YouTube I've got something better than I
can sell wine the next time I feel it
the next time I feel it I'm gonna invest
and that happened a couple months later
at South by Southwest Twitter it gets
better the next thing I invested in was
tumblr and then Facebook it wasn't bad
early in my opinion it was 2008 seven
late seven early eight I had made a
video one of my first business videos
that was titled Facebook should be
worried about Twitter and it was like
why am i starting to use Twitter more it
wasn't like this big grand statement it
was a one person's point of view hey
something weirds happening because of
the way I can use Twitter on my phone
I'm not looking at Facebook isn't
as I used to this is interesting that
goes viral inside of Facebook Dave Morin
sends me an email who was the head of
platform at the time it goes hey this is
like a lot of people are debating this
video would are you ever at you would
you ever come out the Palo Alto and I
give a talk about it I'm like well I'm
going to Palo Alto next week which I
wasn't and he's like okay come by I come
company was so small still no and I gave
a talk about consumer behavior and I I
didn't even know but mark was in the
audience he came down he's like you want
a dinner tonight I'm like yep I had a
flight by the way I had a flight that
night it completely canceled that we hit
it off and and in 2008 a lot of times
when he came into New York he would hit
me up and we got to know each other and
then somewhere in that year mark and
Randi emailed me like our parents are
selling a bunch of Facebook stock do you
want to buy it I said yep so that was
big for me and I was life-changing
life-changing well listen this is two
thousand eight nine ten that's the mark
I know I knew it like when I tell you I
knew it I wish it was video blogging
back then the first dinner I had it was
so interesting to me so I'm built on
emotional intelligence I'm not the
smartest I just know what people gonna
do so he's a tech kid and an engineer at
Harvard kids so I go in thinking he's
that I leave that then I'm like [ __ ]
this kid absolutely gets human behavior
so that's when I knew by narrowly that
he was gonna win cuz I'm like wow he's
got both he knows how to build it like I
can't build stuff I'm not an engineer
that's not what I'm into I'm like but he
understands what I understand that was
it I mean I was just bought into him
from day one he's super smart listen
we're a funny match in a 10 or 15 times
we've interacted cuz I only want to talk
and he only wants to listen that's why
he'll probably end up with the hella
money and be successful but he's
extremely bright I like him a lot I
think he's kind but most of all he just
understands people and that's weird
because people look at him as like
introverted and quirky and all that but
I don't say it and I never saw it
and obviously who more media trained and
grown into himself so I can't speak to
how he rolls down because I haven't
spend time with him but I can definitely
tell you there was no confusion
from from that for those of initial
meetings for me and I mean none so fast
hard yeah I mean I'm sure snapchat would
love to feel like it's an arch-nemesis I
think right now they're on different
scales but yes I love this video that I
haven't - that this is back to
documenting somewhere in 2012 I think
there's video of a fatter version of me
saying all of you will be on snapchat
yeah I mean you know listen I don't
predict much you know this morning when
I wake up and I see there's a app number
one in the App Store it's called face
off or whatever it's called right I take
note I download it
I'll play with it tonight I'll
definitely play with it this weekend I'm
watching I'm not really predicting you
know I jumped on social cam and Yik yak
and pleure and vine and a lot of things
that didn't go on to be humongous I
invested in yo Bongo you know like I've
I followed different trends a lot of one
but I am Instagram is a good one for me
you know because I wasn't a photographer
I was slower to understanding its
insanity you know so for me it's just
about pattern recognition yeah I mean I
think they all have different paths as
you heard right
tumblr I was just David Karp was in New
York right and so I was just I was just
in the same web 2.0 places as he was and
I would tell him things and he's like
wow you really you're really like why
are you older dude talking about junior
high kids in the right way and so for me
it's agnostic right like I'm fascinated
if anybody's listening right now and
you're trying to sell to 50 to 80 year
olds b2b or b2c you can't believe how
well Facebook's working on 50 to 80 year
olds I'm a practitioner I actually use
these things so they've all been
different snapchat I should have
invested earlier I was way on it before
I actually invested I but I don't like
reaching out and never
I still I have not spent a day with Evan
I've spent a ton of time with Emily
white who was originally his right hand
and then Imran and you know I was
bringing a lot of value in her like hey
would you like to invest and I said yes
but if I had the gear and me of like
reaching out and saying like I want in I
probably have left a lot of money on the
table because I would have gotten into
snapchat if I would have had me or Bobby
would have me way earlier what I tend to
do is and you know this is I talk about
stuff in public and I think they talk
about stuff early and I talk about stuff
in a very selfish way which is I don't
want to get into snapchat or I don't
want Twitter to like me or I don't want
you know you to work with vaynermedia I
Gary Vaynerchuk want to be historically
correct because that will be the
ultimate leverage right I own a lot of
Twitter stock and bash it for the last
18 months I sauce it you know I think
you know what I'm proud of if somebody
said well Gary talks and promotes about
the things that he is an investor in I'm
happy to like show people in my Merrill
Lynch account and be like cool let's
talk about it here's what I invest in
here's my holdings here's my financial
thing and like tell me why in the world
I would be saying the Twitter's and real
real trouble and not a good business
model or like why would I be doing those
things or or Instagram literally
literally three months before Instagram
started creating all the features that
snapchat had I made a video or in a
daily vlogs and I'm worried about
Instagram
Facebook's much younger than people
think snapchats exploding in that demo
is there a good spot for Instagram right
that was my point of view and you know
three months before all the stories and
everything came now I don't think
there's a more powerful platform and so
to me I'm not romantic about what I said
yesterday if I said it yesterday it's
what I believed that day and I think my
brand and my word and my legacy needs to
be the North Star so you know they all
happen different ways Nathan you know in
my investments they all come from
different directions
yeah okay that's my thing yes yes yes
yeah we'll do over 125 this year where
does that that comes from clients like
chase and Budweiser and GE and Toyota
and Quaker Oats and an Amazon Prime in
the UK paying us for either spending
their media and giving us a commission
making video productions to distribute
on the social digital web or managing
their social and digital properties and
producing non video content or
consulting for them on their strategies
we're a modern-day ad agency we're mad
you know we're no really different than
Drogo five or AKQA the only difference
is we do everything and most don't
because I'm building it for myself I
don't want to sell it to a holding
company we started doing small business
I come from that world so I mean small
business it's twenty-five thousand
dollars a month so you got to be doing
millions in revenue but yeah we're just
building client service business it's
nothing sexy it's not like I invented
anything the only difference is I'm
really good at marketing in 2009 ESPN
sent me an email and said can you come
to our office and talk to us about
Twitter why do you Gary B have more
followers than all of the Disney
properties combined I don't like these
days I had one point four on Twitter 1.7
on Instagram two million on Facebook so
at the time I'm like 700,000 which was
like like like insanity I'll go okay
I replied you know I was sitting my
inbox because I was busy by the time I
came back to it that night they had
already you know the second time like
we'll pay you $5,000 I'm like I'm coming
right so I go no 5,000
um $5,000 to come and spend an hour
which I thought was I thought I was
insane I I mean I wouldn't take it now
but I mean it was I I'd probably have to
think about like it was really cool and
I was really excited and we had this
conversation and I get out of the office
and my brother calls me now my brother
is now a senior up in you and it's like
February and he's graduating in May and
literally kind of under the gun because
we promised ourselves we're gonna start
a business together and we're thinking
fantasy sports cuz we think it's gonna
be big and we're trying to figure it out
and I call me go Mimi you know how I
talk about maybe one day buying
businesses I'm like instead of getting
that cold maybe you should start a
consulting firm is what I said learn
about corporate America makes some money
and then decide what to do and that's
what we decided to do I got another
email from Gillette the razor company to
like do some sort of like idea session
and so we just started we didn't know
what we were doing we hired four or five
majors friends from college in high
school and we literally started reaching
out to people I started using my network
I was out and about so we landed the NHL
Pepsi and Campbell's and what we did for
them for $5,000 a month was we created
so the NHL's Twitter and Facebook
account did not exist until we created
it we started the company in another
amazing companies conference room called
Buddy Media which sold the Salesforce
that's where we started it we were
literally in a conference room we later
moved to my class or opens his doors and
we just start the company and and the
first two years would happen a couple
months later crush it came out and
that's when garyvee kind of was born
that's my first book and then went real
viral and you did it I did now what was
not reporting there was if my first book
sold enough copies to pay for the entire
ten book advance I would become a free
agent which is what happened now I read
up with HarperCollins but it for all the
Nerds the six people that are nerds of
my content if you look at my first four
books the first one's Harper studios the
others are HarperCollins so it was made
with that weird little division they had
called Harper studios anyway so I wrote
that book it was very
and then I started getting offered
$25,000 to get a speech and that was so
hard to say no to at the time in my life
I didn't which meant I wasn't involved
in Vayner that much the first two years
I got us the clients I would check in it
was really AJ and our band of 20 young
characters in the beginning and the
first juniors show that I think we're
doing like 2 million dollars in revenue
in August of 11 I decided to take over
full time because I was stunned that two
years later nobody was doing what I want
to do two years earlier and I'd realized
oh my god corn America's slow and so I
tapped I saw an opening and I attacked
and so we we stuck I got serious and
from 2011 August 2011 which really means
2012 because I was cleaning up and
hiring in the last five years we've gone
from 25 to 750 employees from 3 to 125
million in revenue I mean now we're a
real player as an agency and we're doing
that at the fortune 500 level and now
with Vayner beta our small business
world we're gonna really go after the
kind of mom-and-pop six Pizza stands for
car dealerships I'm excited because
that's my roots to be fun to me and what
we do for the biggest brands in the
world obviously not as much cuz these
are different but what does a two-minute
Dollar Shave Club not that we could ever
guarantee it because creative is very
difficult but giving a flower shop the
at-bat to make a video right that means
something can change your business for
example for everybody who's buying
Google AdWords if you run a Facebook
video that does well your costs are
gonna go down because your SEO juice is
gonna go up people are gonna share your
Instagram content it's about brand it's
what business insider did so well not
only did you guys do the math thing well
right the search the SEM the SEO you
know you guys did brand right you did
and you have to do both and I'm a good
math and art marketer which means I'm a
Salesman and the branding and marketing
person and that's one we've been able to
help sour patch kids become a monster
brand
stain masters has such a super viral
video right now on youtube that on
Facebook and YouTube
but Facebook that's really helping it's
a carpet cleaner but it's changing its
business because of the strategies and
the creative and I'm proud of that and
so yeah we're building a big agency yes
there's a lot of things I would say the
most important things are a couple
things first of all you have to know who
you are what you are what you stand for
but that is subjective and that's a
cliche marketing [ __ ] jargon but it
does matter it helps you have to know
who you're targeting like you know I
think too many people fight the market
certain people are never gonna want your
stuff like no matter what you do the
soon people because of we are never
gonna love me because I curse them I
have lovato and I'm a Jersey boy and I'm
brash and they won't take the time to
see the humility and the patience and
the truth right and they shouldn't now
Who am I to actually make them have to
take that time so brands have to be
honest with themselves and know who's
gonna buy their stuff and who's not and
most importantly they need to mark it in
a year that they actually live in we
have brands spending ungodly amounts of
money on print television outdoor radio
programmatic banner ads just come
website takeovers like garbage and when
I say garbage they work ish they're just
so overpriced like I don't notice to say
like I do not believe that it is worth
the hundreds of thousands of dollars in
distribution and hundreds of thousand
dollars in costs to make one
thirty-second video to tell a 29 year
old woman that your soap is great in a
world where she is not going to consume
that commercial like I do not think it's
great to spend millions of dollars on
banner ads across the desktop internet
on the right side below the fold of tons
of websites that nobody's ever gonna pay
attention to that banner ad because the
CPM cost is low
merging content and brands and in the
journalism world people start screaming
there is news I think that BuzzFeed is
launching a team of people that are
gonna start like 70 things that you
should want to by people in the
journalism oh my god that's like good
thing they work for a New York Times
does it New York Times has a wine club
in their newspaper joining the dining in
section all that is is romance and
highbrow snobbery
so I heard from three New York I'm
friends of mine Ben Kaufman I was an
adviser to quirky is running that
program at BuzzFeed I think every
publisher should sell stop just what why
not as long as you're honest if you're
it's one thing if Business Insider
creates in business software never tells
anybody that they own it and then writes
articles best ten pieces of software and
number one is theirs that's bad but the
New York Times sells wine the New Times
is a competitor of my family wine
business I don't know what to say they
do so like I laugh when I I had late I
have a lot of friends that work of times
cuz I'm a fan I'm just it was so fun to
make fun of them you believe that
they're the same right they're clad you
know I'm like of course I believe it
you've been doing it and I could I'm
like where are you so yeah I yes I have
I've started something called the
gallery which is so vaynermedia is what
I've been running I've created a holding
company called vane or X vaynermedia
sits on the left on the right side is
something called the gallery our first
purchase was a company called pure Wow
it's in that pop sugar refinery 29 feet
males space yes Ryan hardwood is
somebody I got to know actually through
been they were there were college
friends he was in Goldman Sachs he came
into the publishing world he with Pitman
Bob Pitman they had success with daily
candy so they probably rebooted it pure
Wow probably five six years ago
somewhere around the B round my fun with
Steven Ross vayner/rse invested in it
which allowed me to see how good Ryan
every Cayden that team was then and then
it seemed like they became kind of
available I had become increasingly
aware that vice and BuzzFeed and and Vox
were building creative shops and felt
like they were true competitors because
they had better digital DNA then let's
say the agencies on Madison Avenue and I
thought look I can sit here and watch
that happen or I can do the reverse and
in my great dream of building the
greatest communications and marketing
machine publishing will be part of it
and I never worried about like the
conflicts and things that nature because
everything everybody's doing it York
Times is doing it you know every
publishers Conde and hurt like so that
was easy it's just at an agency had it
done on a publisher because most of them
can't afford it and most of them don't
have to be very frank the ambition I
have like you know when you want to buy
the New York Jets you have to do big
things and Ryan's a really good human
being a really good guy and so a great
partner and I'm excited about it I'm
excited I've been really getting into
the business and you know the same way
I've built my brand and Wine Library I
think I can do a lot of damage
aka really help pure well and I intend
to far the Jets are probably two point
seven two point eight billion dollars
I'm nowhere close to that I do but the
good news is I don't want to buy the
Jets tomorrow
I love the journey of being an
entrepreneur more than I like of the
idea of buying the Jets and so and even
this is Woody Johnson is healthy and
young and not looking to sell so we'll
see how it plays out and if the booby
prize is the Dallas Mavericks lying no
actually she was too young
if the booby prize is the Milwaukee
Brewers will say and maybe there'll be
something altogether different but all I
can focus on is trying to build the
business around giving me those kind of
opportunities
in the future yes yes let's do it
Wow I can't believe you weren't there
this is a tough one it's not you know
that's no it's funny it's not useless
right this has been the one that I've
been very hot on talking about in the
world but I've been scared of but you
think the one you just said that I'm
like ah this guy's terrible it is I
think that people are keeping very
negative people around them and if they
aspire to change their situation it's
imperative to audit the seven to ten
people that are around you and the
reason I go after a friend or a parent I
mean not in the details of that headline
I said hey you may have to do audit your
mom and not that I want you to never
talk to your mom again
but you may want to take a step back and
I've done this for friends and
acquaintances and it's a very painful i
opening experience to realize wait a
minute my dad actually doesn't want me
to be successful because he's not happy
and you know whether he called me misery
loves company and and it's not like
parents are bad people it's a it's a
human trait it's just a thing so to me
in a world where it's much harder to get
rid of your older sister forever it
might be intriguing to say hey I've had
this friend who spends all their time
making sure I'm not going to the next
level and it really came around the fact
that who listens to you to come when you
complain the only groups of people that
will listen to you are the people that
have to your poor family and your other
loser friends right like the other
people who also want to complain about
their boss and yeah I thought it was
actually a very good emotional not
willing to be talked about non
politically correct thing to say maybe
if you got rid of one friend or spent a
lot less time with one friend who's a
real drag and a negative force and added
a positive person in your office as
somebody you now if you switched it from
80 days hang out with your negative
friend and
one day with your office acquaintance
she's super positive to four days with
your negative friend and 12:00 with this
person not only do I believe I've
physically watched me mentor people in
my organization's to a totally different
life on that thesis I think that's right
you don't solve for it because it's the
truth when you're a CEO it's on you
it's Sally's fault it's Rick's fault
like like everything that's wrong
evaders my fault
it just is I don't know my brother left
by the way I don't know if you know this
my brother AJ left I definitely can't
now he's been gone for about a year AJ
AJ has Crohn's disease and the side of
the insanity of the growth was he just
had enough and we've started a jerry
maguire ask thing called Vayner sports
we literally are in the sports
management business and actually of
taping this filming of this I don't know
when you're gonna air it
today's the NFL's rap it's really
exciting our first kind of class and
some of the guys will probably go in
third fourth round so not today but yeah
it's really fun yeah flat out I'm not
kidding like Vayner sports we represent
Jalen reeves-maybin linebacker from
Tennessee's amazing and John Toth Center
from Kentucky both guys are early mid
round kind of guys we've also had Matt
Paradis who's a starting center for the
Broncos and we just signed Braxton
Miller who's a very famous college
player now in Houston as a wide receiver
who I love and Walter pal and a couple
of others so we're just getting going
humble beginnings that's the theme can't
blame me Jay and so it's lonely so
here's what I would say 80% of you were
listening are actually not entrepreneurs
you think you are you're doing it
because it's hot and what you really are
is a great number three a great number
seven and that's why I'm scared because
you're not actually built for eating
[ __ ] and being in fire all day long
you're gonna be more depressed it's even
harder and I think it's time we talk
about entrepreneurship in a real way
because there's a lot
weren't underlining suicide and
depression in our tech startup
entrepreneurial world and nobody has
brave VCS aren't talking about this
people are talking about this and I
necessarily don't want to talk about it
either but it has to be talked about
which is I don't want to be the
entrepreneur who says hey I'm an
entrepreneur and you're not but please
give a real thought if you thought about
dreaming of being a bain consultant when
you were 16 19 and when you went to
Princeton but now all of a sudden you're
the founder of an umbrella company you
need to understand that and I think
we're in a vortex a fake
entrepreneurship that's gonna lead to a
lot of pain so I want to talk about the
loneliness because it is hard I've had a
[ __ ] week I was it like honestly it's
been a lot going on clients internal
stuff it's not fun but it's my calling
like I don't even know anything else I
put in perspective and honestly I love
it but I love [ __ ]
I love the pain I love the process
I'm just watching kids I invested in not
and really struggle and like go to
Coachella and skiing every weekend to
deal with it which that means they're
not putting in the real work to the
business and it just you know and they
would have killed it as number 9 at
Instagram they would have made a fortune
they would have crushed it as number 11
a purple mattress or a Casper
they would have dominated as number 29 a
Business Insider what everybody thinks
no god damn I don't think it's I don't
think it's I think it's the one we see I
think the opposite version of me is the
one we don't see which is there are tens
of thousands about rageous ly successful
businesses of very quiet very calculated
calm executors who are confident you
can't be successful without being
confident they believe in themselves but
I would you know they have their own
version of assertiveness
I'm very assertive when the lights are
on in this interview
on stage I would tell you that starting
daily via the vlog has been a lot of fun
because a lot of
I've been able to see I managed much one
let's call cliche motherly right very
I'm an emotional HR driven CEO so I'm
I'm confident in my advice I'm assertive
in the way that I don't think people
define it as which is I'm I believe in
it but if I don't yell at anybody I
don't you know do that thing so I think
there's a lot of ways to be successful I
think that the work speaks for itself
and I think if you go look at the list
of the 100,000 richest most successful
entrepreneurs businesspeople
there's anaconda amount of names you
never heard of there's a lot more non
Richard Branson's than there are Richard
Branson's it's very hard to be so out
there because you take a lot of heat
just because that's what we do right we
build up the drag down so I think most
people don't actually want it I mean
it's funny I'm going through my rolodex
in my head so many of the kind of more
successful people I know just unknown
just not right you know this you know
business world like so I don't think
that I think confidence matters and I
think and I think other things matter
like I would tell you
empathy is probably why I'm more
successful than confidence I'm in
pathetic to the customer to my business
partners to my employees I they have
their things to worry about empathy has
been a bigger strength of mine than
confidence but uh but yeah I mean I I
think self-awareness right like I listen
I don't hide from being an extrovert
becomes natural to me I can't could
paint it I actually think there's plenty
of negatives that go along with like
being out there but I think whether you
know I see a lot of people who come to
me introverts hey Karen I want to be
like you I want it out there like why
and they're like well you're crushing it
being you need to be more you not a
little bit of me and and I think that's
everybody's good I'll go back I've been
long-winded you've got you bunny in a
very thoughtful zone very weird version
of me
good but we'll capitalize on the weird
so you know in all of your businesses I
feel like rule number one of running a
business is focused you're doing like
ten different things people think I am
let's talk about it which which let's
talk about it which let's talk about it
let's go through it because I think it
will help and will help other
entrepreneurs I think I'm good at making
it look like that so working by having a
vlog and it shows all the stuff it feels
like a lots going on but for example 80%
of my public speaking is only accepted
if I believe there's business
development for vaynermedia so instead
of doing rfp's like Ogilvy I go to CMO
conferences speak real truths and get a
client without spending 4 1 a half
months courting that that's smart that's
failure Media CEO Vayner sports AJ and
team are running it I am just like I was
for vaynermedia the guy that gets
Braxton Miller so yes do I have to fly
to Houston and close it sure we hired
somebody who went to Ohio State that had
a relationship we just started talking
getting to know each other and over the
course of nine months you know we are
going to build a very disruptive sports
agency we're going to make more money
off the field for these athletes than
anybody has ever done because we'll do a
lot small deals we're gonna hustle we're
not just gonna rely on Puma Reebok Nike
Under Armour and panini sports cards so
it's gonna come to us in waves but
that's how just personal relationships
so sports thing Pub takes very little of
my time except when I have to do it or
when I'm deeming a kid who's gonna be
coming out of college I'm Instagram it
takes up some of my time
there's vaynermedia which is 90% of my
time there's being Garrity doing this
podcast but again you know I'm doing
this podcast and I'm also in the zone
right now of where we just opened up
Boehner beta and I like the idea of
being able to get a client or two from
this and I'll be honest I also like
giving back to the things I believe in
number one the entire entrepreneurial
space I deserve it I owe and everything
I will always give my ideas to it for
free forever number two I'm a real fan
of what you guys
down here thank you I just think Henry
and Kevin you like you guys did it and I
think you have to support winning
formulas because it's good karma it's
smart number three I want access to this
audience
40% audience 70% sorry it's never heard
of me as much as I'm out there never
heard of me the other 30% 40% of it
don't like me they thought they think
I'm brash or they think I'm a
self-promoter maybe maybe this changed
their mind so I'm always putting in the
work and then that will feed itself out
so you know I've really calmed down in
my investing because I think there's a
lot of fake entrepreneurship so I've
been I'm Phil Toronto is running point
for me and it's looking at a lot of
stuff but we're looking at I'm looking
at very little stuff you know pure
well-run Ryan knows what he's doing I'm
in it but that's the part of the Vayner
X machine and I don't even know what
else what else am i doing right the wine
business Brandon my dad are running but
sure I'll have a mean with Brandon last
night don't forget I'm also working 15
to 18 hours a day which means if you
really think of somebody's eight-hour
day and you think about 40 hours and
anything about lunch and breakfast and
dinner which I do none of during my
actual day and then you think about no
eat nope and then you think at you are
you at night yep nope are my agent Jeff
senescence Gary's actually a robot
that's what is not happening look I
don't and so that helps and I don't want
read for Business Insider articles in
the middle of the day I'll really met
with one in the morning or when I first
wake up and I don't watch I definitely
don't watch anymore
yeah nope nope um I'm all in an area and
hopping thing like give me six or seven
give me 12 to six every day then I work
out and then I work and so you know
weekends and seven weeks vacation with
my family
extremism uh my work-life balance so I'm
getting a lot done I mean it's something
to aspire to if it makes you happy like
if it if it's not to inspire to make
money I tell I can tell you that right
now you can make ungodly amounts of
money working 9:00 to 5:00 and 8:00 to
2:00 and Wall Street like it's not about
the money it's about the thing to aspire
to that I think I'm a blueprint of
forget about people knowing who I am or
how much
little money and I'm making my life I'm
happy every day you know just because I
want the pain cuz I like the process but
I know the pain is real and that's why I
want to make sure like hey Taryn are you
the founder of this SAS business or are
you the unbelievable CEO or chief
marketing officer and I don't know I
don't know but I know that everybody all
of a sudden decided they were the CEO of
X so self-awareness I need to run and
we'll do this again I promise
self-awareness and then reverse engineer
and put yourself in a position to
succeed
Thanks what's fun yeah how'd it go good
[Music]